في موقع بلومبرج تحليل لمارك تشامبين يرجح
فيه ان حكم محكمه العدل الدوليه سيكون
مكروها من الجميع يشرح الكاتب بالقول ان
جزءا كبيرا من العالم سيكون حانقا لان
الحكم لم يتضمن امرا بوقف الحرب على غزه
بينما سيشعر الاسرائيليون ومعهم اخرون
بالاستياء لانهم لم ينجحوا في افشال
الدعوه ومضى الكاتب يقول لا استطيع
التعليق على ما اذا كان ما قررته المحكمه
قانونيا لكنه نتيجه
جيده في مقال بصحيفه الاندبندنت اوضح وزير
الدفاع البريطاني الاسبق مالكوم ريف كند
ان حكم محكمه العدل الدوليه اغضب الجميع
لكنه في المقابل منصف للجميع حتى اسرائيل
ريف كند المنتمي لحزب المحافظين راى ان
اسرائيل ستبت هج لان الحكم لم يتضمن طلبا
بوقف الحرب اما حماس واصدقائها كما قال
فسيجدون بعض الرحه في الحكم لما تضمنه من
ضغوط على اسرائيل حسب
قوله قال ديفيد كي في مجله فورين افيرز ان
ما صدر عن محكمه العدل الدوليه امس تضمن
في طيته بعدا دبلوماسيا يتمثل في تحدي كل
الدول خصوصا الولايات المتحده لتاخذ
القانون الدولي على محمل الجد في هذا
الزمن المتميز بتنام الصراعات وتراجع
احترام المؤسسات القانونيه
الدوليه ميل اند جارديان الصادره في
بريتوريا اشادت بحكم المحكمه العدل
الدوليه امس وكشفت في الوقت نفسه ان محامي
جنوب افريقيا يطالبون بتعويض الضحايا
الفلسطينيين والخسائر الماديه ويطالب
المحامون كلا من الولايات المتحده
وبريطانيا بدفع تعويضات لقاء دعمهما
المفترض للجيش الاسرائيلي في ارتكاب جرائم
اباده حسب الصحيفه الى الكاتبه في
الواشنطن بوست كارين عطيه التي رات ان
رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو
تاخر كثيرا في الرحيل هو ومنطقه الدموي
وفق تعبيرها واضافت ان كلام نتنياهو كله
يدل على رفضه منحى الفلسطيني اي استقلاليه
وذلك يعني التحكم فيهم او ابادتهم مشدده
على ان تامل كلام بنيامين نتنياهو يحيل
الى رغبه في تطهير عرقي وفصل عنصري ولا
يوجد تفسير اخر له نشر موقع ميديا بارت
الفرنسي تحقيقا عم اعتبرها حرب صور داخل
الحرب الاسرائيليه على غزه يتوقف التحقيق
عند افراط الاعلام المرئي في اسرائيل في
الاهتمام بادق تفاصيل حياه الجنود
والعمليات التي ينفذونها في غزه ويخصص
وثائقيات لكل شيء بما في ذلك الكلاب
المدربه واسماؤها وانجازاتها الميدانيه
واستنفار الطواقم الطبيه بعد اصابه احد
هذه الكلاب لكن في مقابل هذا لا يرى
الجمهور الاسرائيلي في وسائل اعلامه شيئا
عن معاناه سكان غزه خصوصا
الضحايا